on Tuesday in a self-immolating display
of narcissistic stupidity The Daily
Californian which is the student
newspaper over at UC Berkeley ran an
op-ed defending the use of violence in
shutting down a speech by alt-right
popularizer and professional provocateur
Miley innopolis the op-ed titled
violence as self-defense was a whole
series of op eds actually talking about
why violence was useful in shutting down
political debate Nisa Tang an alumna of
the University she wrote to people with
platforms who decide when a protest
should and should not be violent you
speak from a place of immense privilege
as I recently wrote in a tirade against
this brand of idiocy asking people to
maintain peaceful dialogue with those
who legitimately do not think their
lives matter is a violent act this
actually is kind of evil the notion that
words are violence when the words do not
explicitly call for violence that's kind
of an excuse to beat the living hell out
of anyone when you disagree with it's
also worthwhile noting the e innopolis
for all of his myriad faults which i've
discussed at length has never said that
individuals lives don't matter that is a
baseless slur illegal immigrant student
Juan Prieto he explained in an op-ed
titled violence helped ensure safety of
students quote we share our stories and
provide insights of the reality of the
flawed immigration system to out us is
to remove that agency from us in other
words he's here illegally as an illegal
immigrant
so more illegal activity is now
necessary to make sure that his original
illegal activity is left alone got it
Neal Lawrence he's a former at Daily
Californian columnist wrote that the
so-called black bloc this is the the
anti-fascists supposedly was made up of
people with the most to fight for and
the most to lose and did what the campus
should have except that the vast
majority of such protesters actually
live in mommy's basement by statistics
and all the students at UC Berkeley are
sponsored by taxpayers to be there
majoring in uselessness one desmond
meekly wrote quote i put my safety and
my freedom on the line because letting
me annapolis speak was more terrifying
to me than potential injury or us first
off you shouldn't be scared of other
people speaking unless they're violently
threatening you second no one worried
about protesters putting their own
safety on the line it was beating the
hell out of other people we were mostly
worried about finally Josh Hardman wrote
quote the principle of freedom of speech
should not be extended to envelop
freedom of hate speech for the unchecked
normalization of hate speech will have
real consequences if leftist were really
really worried about normalizing Milo
burning things and breaking windows did
more to make him a mainstream victim
than anything he's ever said or done
it gave you an A plus the ability to
done that college Republican outfit on
Tucker Carlson and jump all via an tag
all the ads all the alt-right talk and
pretend to be a normal conservative for
10 minutes the students at UC Berkeley
don't seem to understand the crucial
mistake they made this week that means
they'll repeat it and that's no good to
anybody except for viola i'm ben shapiro
this is the ben shapiro show oh so
there's so much to talk about today as
always but really more particularly
today there's a lot to talk about
apparently elizabeth warren has been
shut down and if you ask how she also
asks how but elizabeth warren has been
shut down by the by the republicans in
the senate I'll explain why I think
that's actually really really dumb in
just a second but first we have to say
thank you so our advertisers over at
legacy box so I am a big fan of the idea
that you preserve your memories from the
past you preserve your parents memories
because after you're gone while you're
here preserving those memories is
crucial and if you're gonna pass those
on to the next generation you got to
make sure that they're in some sort of
form that's not being eaten away by
magnets in the garage so that's what
legacy box is for you take all of your
old tapes and all of your old film reels
and and all of your old VHS ha's and you
throw them in a box and you throw them
to legacy box and legacy box then
uploads all of them and cleans them up
and then puts him back on a thumb drive
or a DVD for you so you can access them
at any time it means that if there's a
fire in your house you don't have to
worry about those 10 boxes of photos
you're gonna lose all of it is on a DVD
all of it is on a convenient thumb drive
they take care of everything they
provide updates at every step of the way
my parents have used it it's really
fantastic legacy box.com / Ben you get
that 40% discount on your order 40% off
and the prices are already good so
legacy box com / Ben to get 40% discount
on your order I don't think that there's
anything really that you could do that's
more important with your money and it
makes a fantastic Valentine's Day gift
makes it great Father's Day and Mother's
Day gift you want to preserve all those
memories make sure you don't lose them
legacy boxes how you do that go to
legacy box calm / Ben okay so Elizabeth
Warren she sent some smoke signals
yesterday on the Senate floor about how
much she hated Jeff sessions and she she
you know participated in the sort of
usual stupidity we've become used to
from Elizabeth Warren and Mitch
McConnell then got up and repper
and told her she had to stop and when
she didn't then the Senate voted 4943 to
gag her no that's not as much fun as it
sounds like didn't actually take her and
put a gag in her mouth or anything
they they they actually just told her to
shut up and then according to the Senate
rule she has to shut up for the
remainder of the Jeff Sessions debate
the big problem here the reason they
could do that is because there's a rule
that's rule 19 we're supposed to stop
you from being uncivil to Senate
colleagues if you if you're uncivil to
Senate colleagues if you accuse them of
things on the floor of the Senate then
the Senate has the right to shut you up
well she was doing issues reading a
letter from Coretta Scott King well Jeff
Sessions was anti civil rights and and
so forth and so on we've talked about
the fact that this is a lie before that
there's no evidence that Jeff Sessions
has shut down civil rights or voting
rights or that he has cracked down
against black people all of that is
false but instead of just letting Warren
spout the Republicans in Congress
decided no we're finally gonna shut her
up and an Elizabeth Warren then
proceeded it looked like this here's
Mitch McConnell doing it
a person who has exhibited so much
hostility to the enforcement of those
laws
the senator is reminded that is a
violation of rule 19 of the standing
rules of the Senate - imputed to another
senator or senators any conduct or
motive unworthy or becoming a senator
okay and then he proceeded to say that
she would not stop doing that and so one
of the phrases that has that has gone
viral now because of this is that Mitch
McConnell said she persisted in doing
this therefore she has ruled out of
order and the sanctions but the boom
come the sanction so very exciting stuff
on the Senate floor okay this is really
stupid this is really really stupid the
Republicans should not have done this
the reason they should not have done
this is because it's super dumb there
are three reasons why this is incredibly
dumb first of all well for really first
it didn't actually silence Elizabeth
Warren after she was thrown out of the
Senate debate she then proceeded on her
own personal Trail of Tears where she
explained everything that she could
about why Jeff Sessions was the worst
person in the world she went on Twitter
and she said tonight on the Senate floor
I tried to speak about why senator
sessions is totally unfit to serve as
Attorney General on the floor I read a
letter that Coretta Scott King wrote in
1986 opposing senator sessions judicial
nomination I spoke out about senator
sessions until Senate Majority Leader
McConnell
to silence me makes it sound like he
clocked over the brick or something so
there will not be silent about a nominee
for AG who has made to raga tory and
racist comments that have no place in
our justice system I will not be silent
while the Republicans rubber stamp an AG
who will never stand up to the president
when he breaks the law first of all it's
kind of ironic since Loretta Lynch and
Eric Holder never stood up to Obama when
he broke the law repeatedly she
concluded tonight Senate Majority Leader
silenced mrs. King's voice on the Senate
floor and millions who are afraid and
appalled by what's happening in our
country and now unless you actually want
to make Elizabeth Warren the nominee in
2020 which is possible maybe you
actually want to make Elizabeth Warren
the nominee in 2021 Pocahontas to be the
nominee in 2020 the reason we call her
that by the way is because she claimed
for years that she was of Native
American ancestry and there is no
evidence whatsoever that she is it's
actually got a job at Harvard they
claimed that she was a member of a
minority and they called her a minority
hire she's significantly wider than I am
significantly wider I mean honest to god
she's significantly whiter than this
piece of paper right here I mean she is
she is the whitest person in human
history but she she yeah said all this
in any case they silenced her and this
is the problem number one they gave her
what she wanted so I let off today's
broadcast by talking about if you want
to give my love what he wants just keep
telling him to shut up all right if you
want my load to get what he wants I have
to do is keep burning things over at
Berkley if you want to give Elizabeth
Warren what she wants more publicity all
you have to do is tell her to shut up
and then invoke the Senate rules that's
number one number two I'm sorry but
Republicans don't get to play the
civility game anymore okay the civility
game is over and honestly I hate the
civility game in the first place I think
the civility game is stupid a lot of
people are very upset about president
Trump because President Trump is uncivil
that's the least of my concerns with
President Trump I don't really care that
much about civility I think civility
it's one thing to say that you shouldn't
go out of your way to gratuitously
insult people it's another thing to say
that you you have to be perfectly civil
on its tee time in the Senate I hate the
idea that the Senate is this place of
great decorum and civility because the
Senate passed a lot of crappy laws I
prefer it when they yell at each other I
prefer when they scream at each other I
like when there's conflict because what
that means is that nothing gets done and
as you know my perspective on government
is that we are best off when the
government is not really able to do
anything
so when Republicans do this roots but it
but it is hypocritical when every time
Donald Trump tweet farts and everybody
on the Republican side immediately
responds with well he has a unique way
of communicating when Donald Trump is
insulting people routinely and people
though well that's just Trump and then
Elizabeth Warren says that the potential
Attorney General is a bad guy and it was
no silence her it's hypocritical it is
and just to be intellectually honest
it's ridiculous to do that okay playing
by the we don't need no stinking
civility rules and then turning around
and saying but civility for you it's a
game the left likes to play a lot I
don't like it when the left plays it I
don't like it when the right plays it if
we're not gonna have civility which I'm
fine with
then let's stop with all the Protestants
about how it's so awful that Elizabeth
Lawrence had stuff about sessions
finally you can't be in favor of
censorship when it's your opponents and
against it when it's you so the best way
to stop elizabeth warren is to let her
just continue babbling like a
nonsensical because she does that
really well she talks and she talks and
she talks and the more she talks the
stupider she sounds right if you
actually want her to lose then what you
have to do is just let her talk and then
you say none of that's true and you're
crazy
that's a much better way of doing this
than by voting to shut her down look is
it emotionally satisfying for a lot of
Republicans to shut Elizabeth Warren
down and make her be quiet yeah of
course it's emotionally satisfying to
put her back in her teepee I mean I
understand but that doesn't mean that
you actually are supposed to do that as
a strategy for winning it doesn't allow
you to win it just makes you look
intolerant and foolish there's no reason
to do it that way so that's my problem
with the Elizabeth Warren thing that
said the Democrats in the Senate are
really making asses of themselves in a
major way so to take an example it's it
is amazing to me that if you if you look
at cory booker a cory booker portrays
himself as this moderate cory booker is
supposed to be this giant moderate and a
few years ago here's what cory booker
had to say about school choice he was
speaking by the way at an event for
Betsy DeVos who's the new Secretary of
Education she's approved yesterday he
voted against her here's what he was
saying just a few years anything was two
years ago at a Betsy DeVos event here is
here is Cory Booker there are people
that say I'm against school choice and I
don't understand that I cannot ever
stand up
and stand against apparent having
options because I benefited from my
parents having options and when people
tell me they're against school choice
whether it's the Opportunity Scholarship
Act or charter schools I look at them
and say as soon as you're telling me
you're willing to send your kid to a
failing school in my city or in Camden
or Trenton then I'll be with you but as
far as I know all the people
representing my city right now I'm not
exaggerating
I've looked maybe I'm wrong but all the
people representing my city in elected
office that have children in schools
let's start at the top I'm gonna be out
there fighting for my president but he
does not send his kids to Washington DC
Public Schools
I got a governor in the state okay we
can stop it right there
so there's cory booker you know doing a
really good job of explaining school
choice and then yesterday he turns
around and says we can never vote for
Betsy DeVos because she's for school
choice it just shows how ridiculous the
Democrats are and they truly are insipid
and ridiculous on these topics which is
why I like it when they talk the more
they talk the better republicanism
sounds the better conservatism sounds no
better case of this than last night
senator Ted Cruz debates Bernie Sanders
on CNN about health care and health
insurance and Bernie Sanders argument as
always it's always the same argument it
always comes down to the world is full
of unfair things and those unfair things
must be made fat by government that
makes things more unfair but they will
be made fair by that same government
because only the government can make
everyone poor and then everyone is fair
fair fair fair I have three houses a
nice car I live in the lap of luxury
in the richest country in the history of
mankind but that has nothing to do with
all the policies that have been pervade
until now the only thing that matters is
that we impute socialism and put it into
we we import it and we put it into
policy here in the United States and
also I would like a pudding Cup right
now a pudding Cup so that was basically
how the debate went last night and Ted
Cruz really sort of destroyed him
because Bernie had no staffs he had no
facts his entire argument last night was
that it was life is unfair poor me
yay government and so he just kept
saying over and over and over that we
spend lots of
on health care and that other countries
have it better and then Cruz would come
back and you would say no and I'll
explain why that's not true and then
Sanders would wander days idli around
the auditorium but it's fun to show some
clips with this because it does
demonstrate the lack of factual
knowledge among Democrats who stump for
nationalized health care here is I want
to start with clip 19 actually this is
this is Ted Cruz destroying Bernie
Sanders his tax plan because burning
says we should have nationalized health
care and the way he's gonna pay for it
is by taxing rich people okay that is
not going to work that let me give you
an example okay the and the National
Health Service in Britain is a
nationalized health care system which
rations and they have all sorts of
severe problems it's basically bankrupt
at this point they have to charge
everybody who makes more than $50,000 a
year in American dollars forty percent
income tax that's aside from all of the
other fees and taxes they have to pay 40
percent by way of contrast in the United
States the income tax rate for people
who make like 50 grand in the United
States as well like 20 percent something
like that it's like half of that so you
know to pretend that you can pay for all
of this stuff just by taxing rich people
is nonsense and that's what Cruz says
and he destroys Sanders over and over
just it's kind of fun to watch Sanders
his face as this happens well but let me
make a broader point on taxes which is
many times in this debate Bernie has
talked about providing health care for
free from the government you know what
the simplest principle in economics is
taun Stoffel there ain't no such thing
as a free lunch the liberal leading
Urban Institute scored Bernie's health
plan concluded it would cost two point
five trillion dollars in the first year
and thirty two trillion dollars over ten
years now how much is that trillions is
a big number it's not clear what that is
when you put it in perspective all of
the federal income taxes we pay today
are about 1.5 trillion a year 2.5
trillion means every one of us paying
income taxes would have to about triple
what you pay in income taxes to get an
additional 2.5 trillion now Bernie no
doubt is going to come back and say no
no none of you are gonna pay just the
rich well how about if we took every
person that makes over a million dollars
a year and confiscated a hundred percent
of their income took every penny that
they make that would raise only enough
money to fund Bernie's plan for 5 months
here's another i-news looking real
awkward how about if the government
confiscated the assets of Apple Google
Microsoft Facebook and ExxonMobil if it
illegally sold the C's those companies
and sold them that would pay for one
year at Bernie's plan if you don't want
to see your taxes triple in addition to
the wait list in addition to the
rationing in addition to fewer MRIs and
mammograms to worse care then you don't
want to see Bernie's Medicaid for all
you want to see cheap affordable health
care that you can choose the rate still
in control yeah great stuff from senator
Cruz right there and it went like this
all night long perhaps the most shocking
incident was there there's a woman named
LaRhonda who gets up and she's from
Texas and she asks Bernie Sanders says I
have 49 employees of this hairdressing
Emporium that I own and I don't want to
pay for everybody's health insurance
because I will go out of business and
Bernie Sanders his answer is and this is
the cruelty of socialism Bernie Sanders
his answer is maybe you should go out of
business
maybe you should if you cannot pay the
health club perhaps you should go out of
business
ignoring the fact that then everybody at
law Ronda's is not going to have a job
and Beyond the government told but
that's actually what he wants right
socialism is all about driving people
out of private industry and into the
arms of the public sector Bernie Sanders
said many times last night he said a
bunch of times that the Medicare is
deeply deeply popular Medicaid is deeply
right because when you make people
dependent on something it turns out that
that thing is super popular with the
people who are dependent on it but here
was this exchange was pretty amazing
this clip eight this is woman LaRhonda
questioning Bernie Sanders and Bernie
Sanders basically saying you go out into
cold and you should die out there you're
a bad person you're a very bad person
I've been living on the public dole for
years why Cannot you also do the same
thing putting it now under Obamacare
I am restricted because I it requires me
to furnish health insurance if I employ
more than 50 people unfortunately the
profit margin in my industry is very
thin and I'm not a wealthy person so
it's impossible for me to grow my
business my question to you senator
Sanders is how do I grow my business
this how do I employ more Americans
without either raising the prices to my
customers or lowering wages to my
employees let me be let me give you an
answer you will not be happy with and
that I think that for businesses that
employ 50 people or more given the
nature of our dysfunctional health care
system right now where most people do
get their health insurance through the
places that they work I'm sorry I think
that in America today everybody should
have health care and if you have more
than 50 people you know what I think I'm
afraid to tell you I think you will have
okay so basically you should go screw
yourself you're a terrible person and
you should fire all of your employees
you should go out of business and then
you should get in a boat off the coast
in the Gulf of Mexico drill a hole in it
and drown that is my plan for health
care Thank You Bernie Sanders well
before we break I wanna play a little
bit more of this but I do have to say
thank you so another one of our
advertisers these are good folks over at
tracker so as I've said many times
before our tracker may have saved my
marriage my wife loses her phone every
single day like every day she also loses
her keys well actually I have to admit I
lose my keys and wallet a lot and we
have tracker at home and that allows me
to find it so tracker is things like the
size of a coin and you attach it to the
object that you're afraid you're gonna
lose and then you can call it and then
it tells you exactly where it is rings
beeps and that allows you to know
exactly where it is if you put it on
your phone it actually allows it to
override the silent function on your
phone so instead of the instead of the
phone just remaining silent which is the
problem right you lose your phone and
then you call it and oh god I forgot I
put it on silent or it died tracker
makes sure that you can find it anyway
so you you pair your tracker to a smart
phone you attach it to anything you find
the precise location with the tap of a
button your phone rings even when it's
on silent if you use it it's finding
over a million misplaced items every day
order yours right now and you will never
lose anything again I promise you I use
it all the time myself it's the tracker
comm the tracker comm promo code Ben the
tracker comm promo code Ben and you get
a free tracker Bravo with any order if
you go right now and use that promo code
Ben great product very excited to be
associated with them and and Thank You
tracker for helping my marriage
because it means that I'm less annoyed
with my wife my wife is less annoyed
with me and since I'm a really annoying
person as you can tell that really helps
me a lot in my marriage means that my
wife loves me more and wants to murder
me less okay so the so back to this is
this Cruz Bernie Sanders debate speaking
of annoying
there was one aspect where I thought
that Republicans are constantly making a
mistake and that aspect is they grant
the lefty premise that profit is bad
instead of just saying that free markets
you know make things better and what
they really should be saying is look the
only reason free markets work is because
there is a profit incentive the reason
free markets work the reason people want
to become doctors the reason drug
companies produce new drugs the reason
that the hospital takes cares it takes
care of you is not out of the charity
and goodness of their heart part of it
is that but a huge part of it is that
they're making money off of it because
no one can afford to be charitable
full-time and so the health care system
is no exception
the reason I say there's a problem is
for example here's Ted Cruz talking
about insurance companies Bernie Sanders
says the insurance companies are
screwing you without making so much
money and Ted Cruz comes back not with
listen insurance companies only make
money by insuring people their voluntary
transactions and you may not like your
insurance company the reason you
probably don't like your insurance
company is because there's not open
competition so the product is worse the
government heavily though regulates the
insurance companies the government now
crams down bad deals on insurance
companies from the state and that's why
your health insurance costs are so high
it's why they've risen under Obamacare
you need to restore an honest and open
free-market with profit incentive so
that everyone can make money right the
idea here is that insurance companies
make money and they should make money
and doctors make money and they should
make money and you should be able to
make more money by paying your insurance
company less that's how free markets
work instead Cruz does this his clip
three in two thousand eight the ten
largest insurance companies America made
just over eight billion dollars profit
in 2016 2015 rather those same ten
largest companies made fifteen billion
dollars in profit insurance company
profits have doubled under Obamacare
that was the result Bernie Hector helped
write Obamacare I don't think the
federal government ought to be passing a
law that doubles insurance company
profits and while though those profits
were doubling what happened to the
average American family the average
American family your premiums have gone
up
five thousand four hundred and sixty two
dollars okay so what he's saying here is
true and he's also undermining Bernie's
argument that Obamacare makes the
insurance companies you know less
profitable but it's also not true in the
long term because the fact is that it's
bankrupting insurance companies which is
why there's so many states there was one
point where Cruz did this he took out a
map showing how many states only have
one insurance company now that Obamacare
has been implemented insurance companies
are dropping out specifically because it
isn't that profitable in the short term
it's really profitable because everybody
is now forced to buy health insurance in
the long term it really isn't
because now health insurance is forced
to cover pre-existing conditions which
means that you can wait till you get
cancer and then pay your $500 premium
and then all of a sudden you have health
insurance for cancer after never having
paid into the system your entire life
this is not the best way to defend the
private market it's basically
undermining the private market even as
you're trying to defend it so I want to
talk a little bit more about this when
we continue over on Daly wire.com you
have to subscribe for that plus I want
to get to the continuation of the Trump
media battle Trump is tweeting and some
of it is good and some of it is not so
good as per our usual arrangement so
we'll get to all of that but you have to
go to Daly wired.com right now to
subscribe $8 a month will buy you access
to see the rest of the show alive we
have our mailbag tomorrow yeah everybody
loves the mailbag but you can't be a
part of it unless you are a member over
at Daly wire.com so go over there right
now check it out and if you subscribe
right now we've just changed our annual
subscription offer you get a free copy
of the wonderful movie the arroyo
produced by jeremy boring of daly
wireframe and and it is a really good
film about the about what's happening on
our southern border I highly endorse it
if you haven't seen it you should if
you've seen it you've probably seen it
on I think that's shown on the blazed
Network a bunch of times I think they've
shown it on net on Newsmax
a bunch of times but if you haven't seen
it you really should check it out great
movie the arroyo you can get that now
for free when you get in your annual
subscription show check that out you are
listening and watching the most popular
conservative podcast in the nation
[Music]